without death there's no evolution as
least as far as we know it
one could hypothesize some organism that
may live forever that would you know bud
off mutations but it would evolution as
it works now operates by organisms dying
and the next generations carry on and
those generations for the most part have
very variance in them and then those
variants are selected and so you can get
a you can get a sort of design happening
out of evolution over time or you can
get adaptations occurring that did not
exist so for example at one point there
were no large creatures such as us or
elephants or dinosaurs or amphibians
walking around on land there were
vertebrates called fish in the world's
oceans and then they were able to emerge
and go up on land the only way that
could happen would be many generations
dying many generations of fish with
certain kinds of limbs dying and there
were slow variations accumulating to
turn those fish into tetrapods
four-legged creatures that would either
be in the mud in the shallow water and
eventually crawl up out of the ocean so
so death has really been essential an
essential ingredient to the evolutionary
process
cells are dying in our bodies all the
time the race that they die in are
replaced varies depending on what organ
we're looking at so for example the the
skin the cells and the skin are turned
over approximately every month of time
your skin is migrating new cells are
migrating outward and the old cells are
slept off and that makes some sense the
skin is a subject to a lot of wear and
tear and abrasion it sits in contact
with the with a harsh environment and so
for the skin to have some kind of way to
renew itself is very essential to having
a border around our body's organs such
as the brain and the heart the cells
there many of those cells are either
aren't intended to die they don't really
have turnover in some parts of the brain
that's being discovered the cells do
have turnover but clearly the places
such as the brain and the heart in which
the interconnectivity of the cells and
the cells working together is really
crucial in those organs that turnover is
a lot less so the body through the
evolutionary process has tuned death in
a kind of adaptive manner to to ensure
that these organs are are healthy
depending on what what function these
organs have to play there's also a role
of death in development that all large
creatures we know have the really good
example is is our hands with our five
fingers the fingers do not grow as stems
of a tree might grow in which they start
small and they just they just grow
outward you might think that that
happens at their starting date of course
they're small when they're in in the
womb but instead the hand starts off
more like a panel kind of like a thick
very thick ping-pong paddle and the
fingers in this embryonic stage are
formed by the cells in between dying off
so the fingers of the first extension of
the fingers are formed by by a
developmental form of death it's a
program death if this is death being
controlled
it's not just the turnover that I
described later earlier of the of the
skin turning over but these cells die in
between and they don't they don't die
and then fall away that they die in or
they're reabsorbed into the hand and so
it's a form of recycling but the the
formation of the hand and this is true
of the human hand the mouse hand there's
many examples of this and if if there is
not controlled what's called program
cell death very precisely sculpting the
the the developing organism it's been
shown that these organisms can die the
death is absolutely essential in the
early developmental process
one thing I write about is the fact that
there's not just one death there's
there's different forms of death there's
there's the death of our bodies that has
to do with the senescence of us being a
large multicellular creature a metazoan
having to do with the slowing down of
the repair mechanisms but there's also a
lot of death inside our bodies as we
live the death of our cells skin cells
are always sloughing off in internal
cells are dying cells that go aberrant
go through a kind of suicide program so
there's a lot of death inside our bodies
all the time going on that is essential
to our life and this is somewhat of a
different death from that from the death
of our bodies as as large organisms and
then there's also death on smaller
scales in bacteria that either have to
do with they're running out of nutrients
that's that that is an inadvertent form
of death but there's also kinds of
bacteria which are multicellular and
they can have programmed cell death in
there as when they go into the
reproductive phases so so one issue
about death that I find particularly
fascinating is that there is not just
one kind of death but death has been
really incorporated into life in various
forms depending on what scale of nature
were looking at